[Music]
Aletha is with us in memphis hi Lisa how
are you I'm fine Dave are you better
than I deserve what's up well they don't
know how to get my husband on board
we've been to Financial Peace University
[Applause]
couldn't get him to cut up his credit
cards then finally got to where okay he
got in the point where I paid off his
credit card he cut it up he turns around
to get another credit card and that's
not his problem his problem is cars he
is he hasn't he's just he's addicted to
buying new cars
he bought a new bought a van in in
November 14th that we didn't need so
that might be more expensive than
cocaine right it isn't cocaine because
he turned around in December 14 got a
Cadillac okay then June 15 the next year
he wanted to trade the van on the truck
so with the vans
Silvia knew we were upside down $20,000
got added to the truck man y'all change
his name to Chevrolet he should own a
company by now you don't know the half
of it we had let's stop let's stop if I
was being at this level of stupid in any
area of my life my marriage would not be
going good because my wife would not be
okay with this level of stupid in any
year and then best feel not helping
because near emerged okay he showed me
under new dodge that's coming out and I
showed you a new one there's a new Dodge
truck whole dodge right a Dodge truck
and he's looking at all the bells and
whistles of it and that's how he's
thought every time he's supposed by
researching these vehicles and next
thing you know he's got to have it gotta
have it God had it and there's always
this amass one well here's what I would
tell you and to sit down and marriage
counseling okay
my experience is this it starts out as a
mild level of aggravation which is kind
of sounds like where you are right now
you're like disgusted you're rolling
your eyes you're like this is ridicu
it starts out at that level but at some
point it turns into real deep worry for
you where you like wake up at two
o'clock in the morning on a cold sweat
and then it goes from worry to a level
of anger that you cannot recover your
marriage from the switch flips and it's
like you've had it
you gave up he's too stupid to be
married to and the marriage is over it
progresses along those lines and so
everyone does by the way and it would be
true if you were married to someone
who's misbehaving in another area if
someone was you know like if you ever
had a friend that was married to an
alcoholic right I mean she'll put up
with it it becomes mild disgust then it
becomes worry then it becomes just this
level of anger that he's never going to
change and I give up on his not willing
to change and I leave the switch flips
and once once that switch flips with a
lot of ladies you can't get it to go
back down it's up it's done she's done
they were both retired and he he he
wants to live the way he wants to live
his heart I think yeah fix him I'm
warning you of what's going to happen to
you you're gonna reach a point that
you're gonna walk out and then go me
anybody can talk you into going back so
you need to say that out loud to the
counselor in front of your husband and
say I'm really not to the end of my rope
but I can see the end of the rope and I
want to stop this before we get there
because Bubba doesn't think there's any
consequences to his stupidity that's his
problem right and you're going to reach
a point you don't even think talking to
me right now you're gonna reach this
point but I can promise you having done
this for 30 years and watch people the
number one cause of divorce even after
retirement is money fights and money
problems and so I want you guys to catch
this and save your marriage I want him
to hear you and respect you he's been
unwilling to do that I want to do what I
want to do is the name of a child I
deserve this I work so hard that's the
name of a child
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good and when I'm
unwilling to make different decisions
for the good of my family I'm a little
boy I'm not a man
and if you're a lady listening you're a
little girl a little princess and you're
unwilling to do the things for the good
of your family you're not a woman
chronologically you may be a woman
physically you may be a woman but
emotionally you're a little child I hope
I just insulted some of you because
that's when I've changed my life on
somebody and salted me sometimes so
there you go because it really children
do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it when
you understand you control your destiny
and then when you plant something into
your life it's going to grow in
abundance including stupidity you plant
stupidity in your life you're going to
get a full crop of it and that's what
he's doing I don't know what this car
thing is other than I'm a boy and I like
cars - I kind of get his car thing but
just because it's a socially acceptable
level of stupidity versus cocaine or
alcohol doesn't mean it's not stupidity
and doesn't mean it's not destroying his
family and doesn't mean it's not ripping
his relationship apart and the fact that
he isn't owning that part of it is a
side is the big issue the cars and the
credit cards and I'm gonna do what I
want my woman and gonna tell me anything
that that's a little boy talking and all
of us have got the ability to be that
guy I've been that guy at times in my
marriage I've been married 35 years
Sharon says we had 28 good years of
marriage we've all had that right but
you just at some point you got to decide
hey the way you win at relationships is
you put other people first not all the
time yeah you have your own dignity you
have your own level of boundaries and
it's not an unhealthy thing but that I'm
gonna actually care if my wife is sick
I'm gonna take care of her she's gonna
care if I'm sick she's gonna take care
of me I'm gonna care that we're gonna
retire broke and I've got to put aside
some of my little boy desires so that we
can retire with dignity and change our
family tree say I want to be Papa Dave
that takes everybody on a cruise I don't
want to be Papa Dave that you have to
give him money because he didn't take
care of himself
either way your Papa Dave but what's
your legacy gonna be
what are you leaving behind now I'm not
the money what are you leaving behind in
terms of your personal reputation with
the way you've behaved as a child or an
adult a good reputation is better than
silver or gold the Bible sings
what's your reputation for your family
what's your legacy what's going to be on
your tombstone yeah that's better than a
car this is the Dave Ramsey show